[Applauso]
ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]
apparentemente non c'è niente di più
lontano dello spazio dal diritto il
diritto regola nostra vita quotidiana
che ce ne accorgiamo meno da una piccola
classe scolastica persino una famiglia
ai grandi rapporti tra nazioni lo spazio
invece è più che altro inanimato almeno
da quello che sappiamo lo spazio una
frontiera di esplorazione di scoperte
scientifiche ma sono lontane da noi
dalla nostra quotidianità quello di cui
non ci rendiamo conto però che invece lo
spazio è tutto intorno a noi e nella
nostra vita quotidiana che ce ne
rendiamo conto o meno lo spazio lo
utilizziamo ogni giorno
pensiamo a ciò che teniamo in mano a gps
che non ci fa perdere quanto tantissimi
oggetti che in realtà sono di nostro uso
comune ma che sono stati applicati allo
spazio per esempio il velcro che è stato
sviluppato per le missioni dello spazio
in assenza di gravità in microgravità è
difficile non far andare degli oggetti
da un lato dall'altro pensiamo al memory
foam o anche il tecno delle nostre
padelle ecco non sono oggetti che io vi
elenco a caso sono oggetti che in
qualche modo sono andati su nello spazio
per poi tornare qui sulla terra
diffondersi e portare benefici a volte
anche molto grandi all'intera umanità
come può il diritto però essere
un'applicazione dello spazio non è un
oggetto non è una tecnologia esiste
dall'alba dei tempi
ebbene quello che a volte sfugge è che a
chi parlò di diritto dello spazio sembra
una pura fantascienza è che il diritto
dello spazio in realtà una materia
vecchia vecchissima e anzi a questo il
suo limite
il diritto dello spazio infatti nasce
con la stessa corsa allo spazio quando
gli stati uniti e l'unione sovietica
hanno iniziato ad avere mire oltre
l'atmosfera l'hanno fatto certo con
scopo scientifico con mire poetiche ma
più che altro politiche lo scopo era
quello di affermare la propria
predominanza in uno scacchiere
internazionale in bilico tra due potenze
ben presto infatti ci si rese conto che
il rischio era quello che quella piccola
bandierina lì sulla luna diventasse
solamente il primo tassello di un
espansione nello spazio non solo
militare ma anche vera propria
espansione nazionale l'altro rischio era
che la guerra nucleare di cui si aveva
tanto paura venisse portata in orbita
ecco perché già nel 1967 parliamo di più
di 50 anni fa prima che l'uomo andasse
sulla luna
l'onu ha promulgato il trattato sullo
spazio il vero e primo trattato che ci
dicesse come l'umanità doveva applicarsi
allo spazio elenca sui principi
fondamentali il primo fra tutto fra
tutti l'utilizzo pacifico dello spazio è
vietato portare armi nello spazio è
vietato fare uso militare dello spazio
tra questi principi ce n'è uno in
particolare che ci tornerà utile per
capire come il diritto può tornare su
nello spazio e tornare qui sulla terra
per migliorare la vita di tutti noi
sembrava fatta il primo grande trattato
sullo spazio di inizio di una
legislazione per una nuova epoca nel
tempo infatti sono state tantissime le
applicazioni dell'utilizzo dello spazio
parlavamo di gps telecomunicazioni
mappatura della terra anche a livello
meteorologico
ma non è stato così no sembrava un
occasione persa
eh sì perché dopo il trattato sullo
spazio c'è stato il nulla quindi per 50
anni la tecnologia andata avanti le
possibilità umane nello spazio sono
migliorate in ambiti che 50 anni fa non
erano minimamente immaginabili e che
quindi non hanno una normativa perché
semplicemente quando la normativa è
stata fatta non esistevano non erano
nemmeno pensabili oggi come oggi ci sono
grandi e importanti aziende che si
stanno preparando a fare scavi minerari
sugli asteroidi per ricavarne i
materiali più svariati
ma il diritto è fermo non potrà rimanere
fermo per sempre l'occasione ce l'avete
qui ne sentite parlare ormai
praticamente quotidianamente la
colonizzazione non è più fantascienza i
programmi sono tanti lo sapete si parla
di colonizzazione cheese lunare come
colonizzazione lunare o anche
insediamenti su marte sul pianeta rosso
chiariamoci quando parliamo di una
colonia non stiamo parlando di un hub
tecnologico tipo la stazione spaziale
internazionale
in quel caso abbiamo se una piccola
comunità umana che gira sulle nostre
teste oltre l'atmosfera ma si parla di
un hub che ha abitato da professionisti
che stanno insieme per un determinato
periodo di tempo al fine di portare a
termine determinate missioni
scientifiche
se noi parliamo di un insediamento umano
permanente nello spazio stiamo parlando
di civili normali cittadini come noi dal
background culturale personale più
svariato che si troveranno a dover
convivere insieme per lunghi periodi di
tempo se non addirittura per sempre
fondando una nuova comunità ogni
comunità piccola o grande che sia per
funzionare lo sapete bene ha bisogno di
regole minime ma ne ha bisogno
regole che permettano non soltanto la
vita di tutti i giorni dei coloni
ma che consentano di evitare che un
esperimento magari tecnicamente perfetto
abbiamo un insediamento nello spazio la
tecnologia ce l'ha permesso diventi un
fallimento perché mancando le regole la
comunità non funziona ecco che cosa ci
dice il trattato sullo spazio lo spazio
extra atmosferico compresi la luna e gli
altri corpi celesti non è soggetto ad
appropriazione da parte degli stati né
sotto pretesa di sovranità né per
utilizzazione od occupazione né per
qualsiasi altro mezzo possibile
sembra una formulazione strana
in realtà ci dice una cosa semplice
nessuna nazione può avere una colonia
nello spazio
questo vuol dire che quando avremo una
colonia la suono sarà una nuova nuova
york una roma 2 una mosca bis sarà
necessariamente una colonia umana non
nazionale di conseguenza questa colonia
non starà le regole di questa o quella
nazione e quindi che norme diamo a
questa comunità
sapete bene che nel mondo ci sono
sensibilità giuridiche molto diverse
magari lo stesso problema viene
affrontato in maniera molto diverse con
conseguenze diverse ci sono paesi che
hanno la pena di morte per altri paesi
magari quel determinato comportamento
non è neanche un reato è esattamente in
questo modo che il diritto può essere
un'applicazione dello spazio sì perché
per dare delle regole a queste colonie
sarà necessario un lavoro molto intenso
di incontro tra diverse sensibilità
giuridiche al fine di trovare quel
nucleo minimo fondamentale di regole in
grado di far funzionare fisicamente
nella loro quotidianità le vite dei
coloni
non stiamo parlando di un discorso
buonista sì vogliamo la condivisione a
livello internazionale è un discorso
molto più concreto che tiene in conto di
tanti elementi anche economici
nessuna nazione potrà andare lassù da
solo
aper forte che sia nessuna nazione né
alle tecnologie sufficienti né le
risorse sufficienti per potente che sia
lo sforzo dovrà essere per forza a
livello planetario
ci dovrà essere un lavoro di incontro di
confronto tra la mia sensibilità e
quella altrui perché saranno i miei
cittadini come i cittadini di qualcun
altro a dover sottostare a determinate
regole e con questo lavoro
dico riflessione di condivisione di
dialogo costruttivo per rial per
arrivare a un traguardo che tutti i
player in gioco vogliono raggiungere il
diritto può arrivare su nello spazio
trovando quelle regole fondamentali per
far vivere i coloni ma di riflesso
arriva anche giu migliorando la vita di
tutti noi perché apre le porte al
dialogo tra nazioni a un dialogo vero
non un dialogo fine a se stesso un
dialogo attraverso il quale sensibilità
molto diverse si troveranno a doversi
incontrare un dialogo che in ultima
analisi troverà il modo di riscoprire sì
quei valori minimi
quelle regole minime il valore dei
diritti umani come regole che valgono
per tutti gli esseri umani
un lavoro che ci permetterà di
ricordarci che quando andremo lassù non
lo faremo come italiani e statunitensi
cinesi francesi chicchessia
quando andremo là su e lo faremo per
restare quando sfonderemo la porta di
casa come tante volte abbiamo fatto
nella storia umana lo dovremo fare come
intera umanità facendo lo commenterò
umanità quando guarderemo verso quello
che saddam chiamava il piccolo puntino
blu pallido nell'immensità del cosmo
non vedremo i confini tra una nazione
all'altra anzi l'unico confine che
vedremo e quel sottile strato di
atmosfera che separa la vita della terra
dalle asperità del cosmo
bene in quel momento noi lo faremo come
esseri umani e facendolo come esseri
umani e in questo ci può aiutare il
diritto riscopriremo di essere veramente
esseri umani di trovare quelle regole
che ci permettono di vivere insieme
oltre ogni barriera costruita o mentale
che sia quelle regole quel lavoro che ci
permetterà di ricordarci che
fondamentalmente siamo soltanto esseri
umani ciao
[Musica]